actions of individuals of bruin bring  shame and humiliation on football and  demand action and change promise all we  cannot allow the reputation of football  and FIFA to be dragged through the mud  any longer we or I cannot monitor  everyone all of the time if people want  to do wrong they will also try to hide  it but it must fall to me to be able t  responsibility for the reputation and  well-being of our organization and to  find a way forward to fix things the  next few months will not be easy for  FIFA I am sure more bad news may follow  but it is necessary to begin to restore  trust in our organization I must stress  that those who are corrupt in football  or in a thinny minority like in society  but like in society they must be touched  and held responsible for directions